[Music]
Peter I'd like to say welcome to Jake's
Place and I wish that this really was a
restaurant but I like a format that's
informal casual where we can really
discuss some
scientific
information what do you think I think
that's absolutely right on the money you
know one can only speculate as to how
many great scientific discoveries
discussions took place in incredibly
informal uh venues yeah I I I kind of
like that oh maybe we should introduce
ourselves uh I'm uh Dr Ronald Chase uh
psychiatrist uh here in New York I'm uh
Peter capano I'm a biology professor at
the City University of New York and uh I
think what we're trying to do is to help
educate Physicians healthcare workers so
that they can have some clarity of
understanding of what seems to be either
the boondoggle or the plague of the
century I agree and I think that it's
important to understand that from an
educational standpoint that uh
professors of biology um Medical School
professors and so on uh have the full
gamut of information that's out there on
HIV and AIDS suppose you tell our
audience uh who we have for them today
well we have Dr Peter duberg professor
of molecular and cell biology at the
University of California at Berkeley and
he was the first one who um proposed
that HIV May in fact not be the cause of
AIDS may not be yeah and he's propos an
alternative hypothesis uh as to what may
be the cause I can't wait to hear
this Dr duberg I'm delighted that you
were able to come and talk with us
primarily because you're such a dynamic
speaker I understand uh that's not a
rumor in any event um are you
comfortable talking about AIDS and HIV
yes I have gotten quite comfortable with
the issue here cuz I feared that you
might get bored at this point but let me
tell you uh what our needs are uh
Physicians I think and I can't speak for
all Physicians and a lot of them have
been out of school for 30 years I being
one of them in order to understand how
to take care of patients with Aids
HIV support life hope uh I need to know
more than what I read in the media and
the media is so
contradictory so I resorted to textbooks
the textbooks are Greek I never studied
Greek but uh the textbooks I don't
understand the journals are
limited uh so I think having a person of
your reputation and ability to convey
the dactic senses makes sense to me what
is it that Physicians need to know about
retrov
viruses actually very little and only
that they are just yet another class of
viruses but one that we see possibly
exception of HIV is known for its
harmlessness particularly for not being
able to kill cells for not being able to
cause a
disease to for its irrelevance as a
pathogen well now I'm not sure I'm
understanding this because having
referred to one of the
textbooks retroviruses seem to have
three or four sub classes or divisions
uh that go from creating
cancers to UNC creating cancers uh it's
confusing those three there's like what
a human uh retrovirus a len retrovir how
how are we supposed to know those
things supposed to is of course question
as I said these distinctions are more
wishful thinking than
reality people when they people find a
retrovirus and there's no disease
then they don't want to discount it as a
harmless virus and they say well this
could cause a disease 10 years later and
then they call it a lent virus lenty
means
slow and if they find this virus in a
cancer patient a virologist would not s
that way either it would be stupid to
did he said well this is a cancer virus
it's a leukemia virus and then they find
it in healthy person and they say well
it would possibly cause the same disease
just give it some time well how well how
do you go about maybe I need to back up
and understand virology
Immunology uh is it some somewhat
similar to being an astronomer where you
scan the heavens and look for ab bareny
uh do you have an idea that uh there is
something that you need to find wrong do
you create how what what do you do it
has become that way your analogy is
perfect it used to be the other way
around it was in the day like 00 years
ago when we didn't know the microbes yet
most of them we didn't know yet we had a
disease and we're wondering what could
it be caused by if it was a contagious
disease we started chasing microbes we
looked either for bacteria or fungus or
virus MH and that is how the most
important the pathogenic viruses were
found and that created the most that
that was the in fact the most successful
chapter in the history of Medicine
the elimination of infectious diseases
MH by identifying them making vaccines
and providing a septic methods to avoid
them and all these kind of things that's
like having a scientific method that is
right yes and it created a generation of
scientists the microbiologists microand
biologists that have now outlived their
usefulness because infectious diseases
are no longer a significant problem in
the western world
and less than 1% of us are likely to die
or getting sick from any infectious
agent
whatsoever that is due to a large decree
because improved standards of living
that is nutrition which we learned the
hard way to to
compete it's due to improv sanitation we
have showers and heated homes and lastly
to
vaccination so on these three on these
three counts we have essentially
eliminated mortality and morbidity from
infectious agent that used to be the
major causes of deaths only half century
ago now they are irrelevant now we are
dying from cancer and other things but
the price for this was we have created
an establishment of microbiologists
biologists who are now useless and
looking for something to do like we have
created a huge US Army to keep Stalin in
or hit check now they're using them to
to uh to to control Saddam Hussein
somewhere in the desert who is not an
imminent threat to to Long Island or
California or to Texas at least not as
far as I'm aware of it so those are the
microb hunters now and what are they
going to do with their equipment if
there are no important viruses left that
cause a disease well they do what you
just said like the ason numers they use
they they aim their most EXP expensive
Scopes that we ever had at irrelevant
viruses now and they're digging those
out of the orifices the vast orifices in
space they go into some lymph node and
then they find the virus and publish it
and say that virus is causing mukim that
virus I found in a in an Alzheimer
patient oh it's causing Alzheimer that
virus I found in a lame goat it's the
it's the
goat C Prim Lio viruses some like that
and so one by one we have more and more
viruses and nothing is going to happen
we have no vaccines to protect against
them we don't get anyway so so what what
should we really be doing uh we we have
patients out there that I have seen in
prisons I have seen when I used to work
in the forensic circuit uh drug and
alcohol programs some of them uh are HIV
positive whatever that might mean I used
to think that the positivity had
something to do with antibiotic
antibodies used to be something that was
good now it doesn't look like antibodies
are good uh they're treated with a and
within a year or two they're
dead uh I have not seen people helped in
the long run uh I became involved with
cases uh during the Vietnam war of
posttraumatic stress disorders following
that drug abuse created not only PTSD
but HIV and AIDS uh how do you deal with
any of this what what is this all about
are there stress factors involved uh in
AIDS or are are the professionals just
stressed I think you almost revealed the
common threat here in Vietnam they were
using drugs those in prison are using
drugs and others are being given a we
are talking about either recreational
drugs that are tox
or medical talks that are even more
toxic Act is a chemotherapy that is the
one thing they have to look out for and
those are always the same correlations
those are the people who get AIDS they
have been using one or another type of
talk the harmless antibodies in fact the
beneficial antibodies if HIV were a
cause of a significant disease those
should be the ultimate protection they
should be highly beneficial as they are
with any other virus
those are not our problem the problem
are the med medications
given against is thebly or for this
whatever for the for the prospective
disease or the medications that got
those people that come to see you in the
in in the same cble that that you find
them in your practice I assume or in
your prisons well well well in practice
looking at medication I'm basically a
neist when it comes to uh medic ating
patients uh I have known for a long time
that in treating patients that were
receiving a that were in methodone
programs uh things of this nature they
were positive uh they were diagnosed as
having AIDS that they would like to have
something to relieve stress often times
they would ask for benzo deaza pan uh
volums and in looking over the benzos
you find that the side effects include
neutropenia to justify giving someone an
antistress and an anxiolytic agent that
also could contribute to the very kind
of disease process they're supposed to
have never made sense to me but yet the
PDR is rampant with medications that
influence the granulites the nutrifil uh
the they touch on the immune system uh
are are you saying indeed that not only
recreational drugs but also these are
iatrogenic failures or well the Act
without any doubt the Act was developed
for one purpose specifically for
chemotherapy that is to kill cing human
cells in the process of cth growing
growing human cells cing human cell King
growing human cells that's the operating
principle of chemotherapy you call all
cing cell you kill all cing cells and
the strategy is the cancer is usually
one of the most aggressively
persistently coing cells so if you
continue to kill for a limited period of
time if your strategy works out the
cancer will die before the patient dies
and that's when you stop the therapy so
the cancer is dead and the patient looks
like hell and chemotherapy has then
worked the patient will recover there
will be a lot of collaborate
collaborative damage but it is better
than having him die but here we are now
using these heavy guns on people who
have nothing wrong with them but
antibody against HIV or had past
recreational Tru on their record and now
we treat past the damage of past
recreational trucks with the incredibly
direct and toxic damage
of new trucks like act so so where do
the retroviruses come from why does it
appear as though they're a neoc creation
is M that they all of a sudden mushroom
uh 10 years ago and now all the emphasis
is to eradicate them uh I I'm not sure I
quite understand I tried to explain this
by by this analogy with the military
here was an establishment that had
served its purpose that identified all
the significant microbes that are going
to make us sick or kill us occasionally
and have solved that problem and now
they're sitting there uh obsolete
because these microbes are all in
textbooks and all in the medical
registration we don't need any further
they're all there so what are they going
to do they look further they're using
bigger Scopes and with bigger Scopes you
see new
stars naively you would say oh here is a
new star it wasn't here yesterday but
the problem is you're using a 10 times
stronger scope you see someone that was
here a long time ago but it was so
inapparent so inactive so nonpathogenic
that we wouldn't see it but is it really
a virus yeah it is a real virus it is
yes it is a real virus yes that I can
tell you with the authority of 30 years
working with these things so so it is
because I've heard and obviously these
are all anecdotal reports you go to
enough meetings read enough literature
and articles in the paper they range
from there is no such virus uh to there
is an established virus that it's a
benign virus that it's a a a a virus
imbued with high
lethality uh we really do know what it
looks like this virus yes we know enough
about it the the battle lines are
between those who claim it's pathogenic
and those who claim it's not and they
have no proof as at this
point 13 years after discovering the
virus and $50
billion uh in after investing $50
billion in its in its understanding in
ation there have no clue no proof that
it's penic yet so you're really saying
there is an establishment that has put
the inomata on it saying it is a
pathogen uh without proof and yet there
are others like you who uh can't find
the the proof scientifically to say that
it is a pathogen that is well yeah
that's right yeah that's exactly I so
this is very similar to the world of
philosophy and Aesthetics I think
William B be uh termed how does a
classic become a classic because only
the few people who understand what it's
about will say it is therefore it is
yeah everyone's a follower yeah it's
probably right yes so so how how does
the medical establishment actually get
information I mean I I don't understand
you can be in a laboratory and making a
discovery or making the antithesis of a
discovery that something does not exist
if there is way to say that how does
that actually filter into the medical
community to be able to utilize uh does
it pass through the filter of a
pharmaceutical company through uh how
how does it all go from your desk to my
office well you know the media now
they're everywhere you have your website
and you have your emails and you have
your conferences and you have your night
line and you have the New York Times
half a third of it once or twice a week
now is science you have Scientific
American you have break through reports
in every newscast we have a break
through on a we had several hundred
breakthroughs on AIDS except nobody ever
got cured so we have our weekly or
monthly breakthrough on AIDS we have our
weekly or monthly breakthrough on cancer
so we get we hear it from Dan Rather and
when you if you are real professional
you check in the library are you ask
your sales from Hoff what's actually
going on here or you go to the next
conference in Florida or in in cre or on
a creek Island and find out exactly what
you what your colleagues are telling you
and that's what you bring home well so
so medicine has really grown so vastly
and so highly specialized that when
AIDS spreads
to uh so many physician areas so many
Specialties everybody comes in contact
with an AIDS patient yet not every
specialty understands AIDS in the same
manner is mind bogling uh how how to
actually get
information
uh is have you written something that is
uh precise for Physicians so or do you
give courses in uh for Physicians I
don't give courses for Physicians but I
have written a couple of papers that are
written to be understandable by non
biologists of non biochemists this is
one example this one inventing the bi
that's quite readable I assume it's
written for real of Scientific American
for example yeah but suddenly an empty
or PhD would get more out of it than the
reader who has no such background but
there are some other scientific papers
that have written but it's very
difficult these days to write anything
that is not conformist opinion and and
that has to do with the way money is
handed out for research and funded in
Laboratories and in Academia these days
it's very dependent on approval of your
peers and an approval of companies who
stand behind it as well so in some way
you're like in the entertainment
business uh they can make stars uh if
their proper disc jockey will play your
tune uh you get coverage that is exactly
like it you right here
that's unbelievable you see the same old
Heroes uh every month on television
anony F particularly he's there once a
week and then you see Bas or Baltimore
or fing or J Le so announcing there as
as said weekly or annual or monthly
breakthroughs that add up to nothing for
the customer except for them for the
next conference well this is interesting
because I saw just a few weeks ago that
a Nobel Prize was handed out for pre
now in trying to understand HIV and AIDS
now I have to put this into the hopper
to understand what the prion is now how
far is this going uh I'm beyond Medical
Practice when I'm looking at prons it
seems as though we are at an interface
of discovering uh how life comes to be
this is a almost Blasphemous it's life
in a in a jar well there's no life in
pan this the claim is certainly
extremely controversial the claim is
made that we have here an infectious
protein that is with regard to
everything known today including
publications of the Nobel Prize win
stand P completely unexplained
completely unexplained and totally
incompatible with uh any current
knowledge it postulates that you would
go the central dogma says the flow of
information goes from DNA to So-Cal RNA
these are two forms of nucleic acid down
to prot chains which is the working
molecules structure molecules enzymes
that we are made of and here this man is
actually saying it's going
backwards it's like it's scientifically
spoken almost like somebody's saying
okay let's start try let's start trying
to eat from our rear end I mean in
totally Theory it's possible but it's
very very very unlikely
we probably will have to wait a long
time to find
proof that is an interesting
concept so so all all of what we're
saying is that there are groups of
people that have a
predilection um by virtue of lifestyle
or do they have a genetic predisposition
because of who they are where they came
from or is the final common denominator
bone marrow suppression in AIDS you mean
now yes it is not even that uh AIDS is a
rather halfhazard collection of diseases
and a denominator of about a majority of
the diseases is indeed immun
deficiency like all the infectious
diseases that are observed in AIDS
patients the denominator of all
infectious diseases are that your immune
system is to some decree defective
seasonally
temporarily or chronically and then
you're subject to infectious diseases
but a significant percentage of AIDS
diseases has nothing to do with immune
deficiency and one of them is in fact
the signal disease of AIDS at all capos
zoma it's a cancer or sort of a cancer
that has nothing to do with imun
deficiency capos Aroma is observed in
people who are as immune competent as
everybody else who have no immune
deficiency
and PE and and people with uh an intact
immune system can not fend of kosi
saroma so others include weight loss or
dementia none of these diseases are imun
deficiency diseases so the there is no
common denat no known functional common
denominator for its diseases the only
denominator is entirely
arbitrary and that is the CDC or the
AIDS orthodoxies one and only
denominated they say if any one of these
30 previously known diseases occurs in
the presence of antibodies against HIV
then we calling it aids that's the
common denominator and that is also the
key to what they always flaunt or HIV
must be the cause of AIDS because we
have such a wonderful correlation the
correlation is the definition of AIDS I
see so what happen happened to those uh
precursor terms um acute uh HIV positive
mononucleosis uh Arc uh AIDS related
complex what happened uh they have
fallen into disuse where did they go
they are not s whatever you call
official in that business but they're
not sort of official terms people like
to use them like to say we are a little
pregnant and not totally pregnant yet
but they're not they have no real
significant official meaning I see when
when um patients have AIDS and they are
given
a not any physician can prescribe a uh
you need to have I think uh meet certain
standards you have to belong to an
organization in which you have a
collection of uh 30 such uh patients how
does it work that a is um
harmful yeah I doubt that the first part
of your point is in fact correct as far
as I know anybody can prescribe AC the
food and talk Administration has
approved to it everybody can prescribe
it for anything in this country oh is
that true I you can prescribe it for
dant and you not punishable well that's
like using Napal to cure the weeds in my
garden I that's happening all the time
and it's the same with what we doing
with act we you can prescribe it for
infected prescribing it for something
like that of this is the sasis it's a
bit like it and people prescribe act for
that since it's approved by the FDA you
can prescribe it for anything you want
in fact they prescribe it for nothing
for people who have no disease
whatsoever and have antibodies against
the virus and they prescribe it for
people or about to become people who are
not even infected by HIV namely f and
unborns they get act to
prevent a hypothetical infection from a
mother they get it for the first or the
second six months in their life or okay
the
first the from the four the second
trimester on they get every day act well
I I know that there is a policy uh in
New York state facilities if someone has
a needle
healthcare worker he can get it uh they
must offer that kind of treatment within
24 hours now is this HIV so virulent so
uh rapidly multiplying uh replicating
that uh uh there's an urgency to uh well
the urgency is a bit again like uh
contraception if you if you wait too
long and it is too late I'm afraid to
say that's about it that's not more
serious than that so there's no radio
fluoresence no no no no no it's only
that it won't help after next
week
oh let me think a minute of of what I I
would like to ask you because there are
so many things that uh that impact on
the treatment of patients that uh it
seems uh as though the the the the
direction that needs to be taken is to
rethink whether or not
uh these patients should be treated at
all and and and if they're not treated
uh what happens to
them if they're not traded I think they
would be extremely well off if they not
traded for HIV they would be living as
long as God had in mind for them but if
they of course take recreational talks
which uh 97% or 6 5% of All American and
European AIDS patients do then that has
a major say in what's going to happen to
them if we can get them off those
Parks then of course that would help
them Cate deal the third of all American
AIDS patients are intervenous talk users
and about 60% are male homosexuals who
are using sexual stimulant talks as
sexual stimulant so those have a major
say in in their in the
future what is the mechanism I'm not
aware of how uh nitrites for example
or other recreational drugs cocaine
heroin how does that actually affect the
immune system see uh we have to go back
on in the literature to figure this out
or or judge it from basically knowing
the chemistry of some of these fogs we
have no studies now anywhere in this big
country on the consequences of toos
recreational toos a long-term
consequence of this except the
consequences they studied but what 20
million Americans do not one American
doctor or not one American researcher a
research institute is studying that
is regular
use addictive use of recreational talks
20 million Americans do it nobody is
studying we have instead about 20,000
researchers studying HIV in this country
about 20 for every nucleotide of this
virus
so um what what could these talks do
well the cocaine and heroin act very
much like catalysts a bit like hormones
like adrenaline things like that they
are operate on that principle in fact at
what level at a catalytic level like a
hormone works they can make you high or
low like a sex hormone they Thrive you
this to do one thing or another thing
give you fantasies and things like that
or get you excited like a telas
that is what cocaine and amphetamines do
and heroin somewhere I don't know it's
like an anesthetic bit but but in
relationship to the immune system on a
there's no cellular there's no direct
consequence on the immune system in this
now that comes in a minute now if you
are uh if you're using these talks
regularly you have to look at this at
the second at the indirect effect of
this they cost you daily about $100
so unless you're independently wealthy
you have to beat up a little old lady or
somebody to get you $100 then you have
to buy the to then you have to shoot
them up and then you're out of it for a
couple of hours so half of the day is
gone by the time you are starting your
day so it's probably too late to show up
in office so now you get a fast food get
some coffee and some donuts and then you
chase the next talk again in the
meantime you haven't slept you haven't
eaten and so you're so far in the red
that you can't pay your rent anymore
then you start moving into the park and
then 5 years later you show up in a
hospital with tuberculosis or dementia
and then you get a great psychiatrist or
Aids doctor he finds HIV in your body
and helps you to the cemetery with act
and then the story is over so that's the
fate of your typical uh long-term talk
user with night time inhalence and it's
it's a it's a chemically more clear cut
nides are react with all micro molecules
the poers in the body with proteins DNA
and RNA so they're directly cytotoxic
they kill lung cells liver cells blood
cells and change enzymes and mutate DNA
and as such can also possibly induce the
kosoma cancer which is diagnosed in the
thir of all patients in the lung as lung
cancer kosis as a as a lung as a lung
cancer in the third of all cases in the
lung it's inhaled in lung that's the
primary exposure okay of course that's
ectoderm uh
MH understand I I thought that I read
somewhere where the Kos s coma um was
due to a virus that the Italians had
isolated was that uh not another uh
American Italians or Italian Italian
Italians I see well American Italians
isolate all the viruses here for us now
I know Italian Italians
anym it's the fou and The Gallows they
so there's a
conspiracy know they have a neck for it
they they know what the Americans expect
from them spaghetti ores I assume let
let me let me ask you this since some of
the risk factors involve here um deal
with a lifestyle of sex and drugs and uh
being involved with nefarious characters
whatever happens to the world uh in the
world of prostitution and Co girls uh
you would think that uh there's a lot of
rampant sex or or or sex is it is is the
incidents of um Pro prostitutes with uh
HIV and AIDS High then uh I don't know
who to compare that to no the
prostitutes don't get any AIDS unless
they are junkies that's one of the many
Paradox of the HIV aids hypothesis they
don't get they were the first ones to
get AIDS but they don't get it what do
you mean they were the first ones to get
it but they don't get that was predicted
they they would be among the first to
get AIDS from HIV because HIV is said to
be a sexually transmitted virus well who
predicted that that was predicted by
Gallow and by by marget Heckler the
Secretary of Health and Human Services
by Surgeon General Coupe by fouchi by
the Centers for Disease Control the
leeding players in the Orthodoxy on AIDS
they predicted these were the people who
would first get eights but God spared
them miraculously how do you suppose
that happen well God you know this is a
very smart virus it discriminates
between boys and girls and homosexuals
and heterosexuals and junkies and non
Junkies you got to start that a long
time before you fully understand
it I guess that's why we're we're all
having so much difficulty in
understanding
this well I I I really wish that we
could talk forever um I've really
enjoyed speaking with you and uh I would
hope that perhaps we could meet again
and um speak with colleagues and try to
get a greater understanding of what
their needs might be in order to focus
in on what this Aids HIV versus drugs uh
ideologically uh the controversy
is thank you thank you very very much
thank you on
Chase a
pleasure so we used two not two hours
now I don't think so no but you have
enough I would I would think so I mean
that we have
okay we're going to go in 10 9 8 7 6
five all right so I I would understand
that the virus uh I mean do you refer to
it uh in your circles as the virus the
AIDS virus that seems to be a difficult
pill to
swallow um HIV AIDS why so much uh
selectivity among risk groups how does
that work the selectivity is actually
better uh explained if you look at AIDS
than the virus the virus has essentially
two two different distributions it has a
natural distribution that is from mother
to child and that doesn't follow RIS
groups and another one so-called
horizontal transmission where you can
have sex with somebody infinite number
of times and then you pick it up that
way or you exchange needles or
transfusion you pick it up that way but
what's more telling since we all want to
know first what is causing AIDS is to
look at how AIDS is
distributed and that is very non-random
in the American and European population
un nonrandom totally non-random unlike
any other infectious disease we have
ever seen for
example based on SE sexual distribution
AIDS in America and Europe is 86% male
now for 15 20 years since we know it 86%
male that is uh like day and night is
compared to what all other infectious
diseases are which are equally
distributed between the Sexes right that
yeah that doesn't make sense like polio
would be 50/50 one would think uh
measles uh hepatitis measles mums cilis
tuberculosis all 50/50 syphilis we're
not talking about that as a virus though
well all infectious diseases are 5050
all right that would make sense be
generous so
microbes yeah but but not AIDS and then
it becomes even more selective or even
more nonrandom within the boys it's not
only heterosexuals it prefers the
homosexuals 60% of those males that get
AIDS in America and Europe are male
homosexuals whereas male homosexuals
make up at the most 10% of the male
adult population perhaps even less so
their share is way out of proportion to
their representation in the population
so that's like saying a virus would know
who was gay or who wasn't gay exactly
that's virus knows that too that's a
smart virus extremely smart and that's
not the end of it it knows even more it
doesn't evenly distribute those diseases
either in the population they are also
nonrandomly handed out dished out to
different coups Capi zaka is the best
example that is found exclusively in
male homosexuals and not in heterosexual
junkies or homosexual junkies well you
can't tell them apart easily but females
or babies or hemophilia do not have
kosis
Aroma it's a very non-random
distribution in in the population with
regard to
epidemiology that this distribution in
the population also with age AGS uh
breaks all known rules typically
infectious diseases are in the very
young and the Very Old Well in Bal
diseases of course are different in that
regard they start in teenagers and go up
all the way as long Sexes but usually at
old age people are not that promiscuous
so they cop down but they sort they have
a high incidence in teenagers and in
young twins there's no AIDS in teenagers
nowhere in America and they have a lot
of sex but why is this happening in this
kind of a distribution because it's not
a virus it's not an infectious disease
AIDS fits all criteria of a behavioral
disease of Behavioral disease a
behavioral disease a behavioral disease
could be like a psychiatric disease or
well I I should probably be more
scientific about it otherwise I get
trapped by a psychiatrist um I never
never never be on the couch and in a
minute so behavioral is a word that I
didn't choose initially it was the
sentence for Disease Control who used
that word it's a euphemism for Dru
disease because virtually all AIDS
patients early on were all intren or
overal uses of recreational clocks and
they are now just the same
way and a of All American AIDS patients
confirmed by the Centers for Disease
Control are intervenous Str
users and two3 are male homosexuals who
and that's a small what should should
make that clear it's only a small
faction of the male homosexuals who are
having hundreds often thousands of
sexual contacts in a matter of a few
years and that is achieved not with God
dos like testosterone and estrogen but
with human trugs like with chemistry
like we break the records in the
Olympics so we break the records in the
bedrooms with chemistry so and and these
people take nitride inhalence they take
amphetamines they take cocaine over
weekend without sleep without food
without maybe with a little alcohol with
little cigarettes on top of it and they
have 30 or 40 dates per weekend but if
this epidemology this this distribution
the
demographics would indicate percentages
85% male in this
country what is the comment of the CDC
regarding that in terms of the validity
of the
hypothesis they keep saying if they do
comment at all in the beginning they
said well this is how it started it was
first introduced from Africa from The
Jungle of course somebody was raping a
monkey or dating a monkey there and came
home and he happened to be homosexual
and came home and dated his homosexual
ual friends here in
America and so they were the first one
to be infected that's what the CDC would
say and it has stayed that way ever
since because homosexuals are very
faithful to homosexuals I take it that's
what they argue but what they don't seem
to address is that a lot of homosexuals
tend to have kids that are
bisexuals and some of them are hop filcs
and give and take blood and the first
women with AIDS were diagnosed with a a
year after the first men with AIDS were
diagnosed blood transfusions were
positive hemophilia were positive this
thing should have long equalized in the
general population that was a good
argument for a year or two after eight
was first introduced now it has
completely lost its cability and
therefore the CDC won't say a word about
it anymore now it's just there in
statistics for you to think about but
isn't it that infectious diseases follow
some kind of uh principles and and laws
uh exponential laws of spread that's
another indication that this is a
behavioral disease a typical seasonal
flu comes up within a few weeks or
months and then whoever susceptible gets
it starts sneezing huffing and coughing
dying or covering become resistant and
here with AIDS we have go we have sort
of a slow steady
increase of a very small percentage of
the susceptible population after all the
probably 100 million sexually active
people in America if not more probably
more over over 150 million and we can't
get over 50,000 AE cases per year If
This Were a new sexually transmitted
disease against which we have no
vaccines no effective treatment that
thing should go up just like sex skills
why do you suppose we don't have a
vaccine uh I I I read that we do have a
vaccine or one is imminent uh you'll
never have a vaccine against AIDS if you
try to to aim the vaccine against the
virus that doesn't cause it that's what
we doing well that could be a hell of a
great Money Maker couldn't it not if it
doesn't help well it it it yeah it does
that too but it doesn't help it it money
is is no problem in AIDS the American
taxpayer without asking questions pays 8
and a half billion Faithfully every year
into it because the government says
that's good for us they do they never
ask any questions if they do then anony
fouchi hits the tube and tells them if
you don't do it your daughter come or
your son coming next to you to college
will get raped and will have AIDS so you
better keep paying and you do pay so
there's a conspiracy here conspiracy
well good I don't think it's quite a
conspiracy as I said another occasion
there it's I think that's all these
people know so that's what they do I
don't think they are geniuses Evil
Geniuses who have many options and say
let's choose this one to mislead the
American taxpayer MH they are let's say
it's not a conspiracy that Americans
prefer to speak English they simply
don't know Chinese or German and that's
the same with these people these are HIV
researchers who do nothing but HIV well
why is it that they're so so little in
the media
concerning dissident views uh
alternative views for for the very same
reason the only thing that this
immensely uh supported Orthodoxy
immensely Rich affluence Beyond any
belief in the history of infectious
diseases cannot afford is a challenge to
the basic Foundation of its hypothesis
that it's of infectious disease they can
afford everything in the world but not a
challenge that would question the basis
of their Investments their affluence
their weals their CS their recognitions
their Awards and their companies that's
they cannot afford so they have to
exclude that and they do effectively
exclude it in the press as well we have
a whole generations of science writers
who have done virtually nothing but
writing eight stories larryman from the
New York Times Gina kada from The New
York Times U she or
of main day What's that name know the
one from new day that
girl they have all the a Riders The
Washington Post Perman in the San
Francisco Chronicle they have made their
career by writing one eight story after
another for them it's too late to say
maybe all of our stories were
or Garbage
worthless they cannot like the
researchers they have invested too much
to change their stories now so they're
they're almost a a parasite that really
can't destroy its host that is about
right
yes